Let's go next to Alex from Orange County.
Alex from Orange County. You're on the air.
Hey, did you hear? Yes, I can.
Hey, David, so I've been noticing that there
is a lot of infighting and waffling spaces,
but I've been hearing a lot of infighting and
right leaning spaces, such as Republicans refusing
to vote in the Georgia Senate election. So do
you think there's a lot more infighting in these
spaces? But we don't know about it because
we are not like we don't hang out in those
spaces or do you think it's like the same?
That's a good question. I think, you know,
why would it be the same? So, no, I don't think
it's the same. But I think that the nature of the
infighting on the left and the right then tends to
be a little different. Like, for example, earlier
this week, I did a big segment about how I think
Neera Tanden is a disastrous cabinet pick by Joe
Biden. And I explained why. And I made clear that
I don't regret voting for Joe Biden. Obviously,
the majority of Joe Biden's picks are fine and
certainly better than the people Donald Trump has
in power. Some might call that infighting, but at
no point do I have any doubt about what the right
thing to do in terms of who to support is. So
we have to look at the nature of the infighting.
When you look at what's happening in Georgia,
where there is a movement to boycott the election
altogether because Georgia officials aren't taking
seriously enough Trump's claims of voter fraud,
that's in-fighting of of a degree that has a very
different impact than me saying, hey, I wish Biden
had picked somebody else. So I think it's less
about the quantity, but really looking at the
impact of the infighting or the disagreements.
Not like I, I do. And see what you understand,
but also remember after the election, yeah, a lot
of the Democrats are saying, like people like AOC
and rhetoric like defund the police is hurting
the Democratic Party. So I was like I was thinking
of things like that, you know what I mean?
Yeah. I mean, listen, there are disagreements over
defund the police, but understand that in the
actual Democratic Party powerbrokers, there's
very few people who actually want to defund. They
really want to reform. When you look at, you know,
almost all Democrats ended up voting for
Joe Biden. So I think that if if what you're
talking about is is there spirited debate from
different factions, the answer is absolutely.
Is it happening in a in a way that's
that's destructive? It doesn't really
seem to be right now. And if it if it does
become that, I will absolutely call it out.
OK, because I hope this doesn't affect the
midterm elections in twenty twenty two. Sure.
Well, yeah, we and we've
got time until that happens,
but I think your concern is a reasonable one.
OK, thank you so much for taking my call.
My pleasure. Thank you for calling
in. Very, very much. Appreciate it